[Music]
a conservative estimate of how much your
personal information is worth to these
data brokers is on the order of two
hundred and forty dollars a year for
each of us for millions and millions of
people and that adds up to a really
really big number and a lot of that data
right and the advertising against that
data is just getting sucked out of
conventional sources and going right
into the pockets of the big data brokers
like Facebook and Google and even Amazon
but also a whole bevy of smaller data
brokers you know people who run little
websites like you know housekeepers like
me and you know do you have insurance
and are you in the market for a new car
and people willingly hand over this
information which then gets aggregated
and copied across databases and then put
into this package which advertisers can
then use to target you I think we're
just at that very early stages where a
few people are sounding the alarm but
that has not spread out to the masses
yet I mean all those people posting
about their grandkids on Facebook don't
understand the minute that thing goes up
on the internet they have lost control
of it they don't own it anymore and the
minute you do a quiz or the minute you
volunteer any information about yourself
I'm sorry
it's their data not yours I think it
kind of crept up on them by accident I
mean ever think about how Google for
example got into the data business it
they had built this fantastic search
engine but they had no way of monetizing
it and it wasn't until they figured out
that you could sell ads against search
and in the beginning it wasn't
collecting personal data let's not
forget that in the beginning it was if I
go in and search on tennis rackets and
you show me an ad on tennis rackets
that's kind of okay like that doesn't
bother me that much it's when you start
to get more pervasive and I think where
they cross the line maybe without
intending to but where they started
across the line was when you start
targeting when you start saying I can
get you you know ads posted to 14 year
olds living in Princeton New Jersey who
wear kid's tennis shoes by the time you
get that level of precision posting or
targeting I think that's where you've
crossed a line and I think we've gotten
ourselves now into a situation where a
lot of people are going hey what you can
do that and just as an example so
Facebook can actually allow people that
want to rent an apartment to exclude
African Americans exclude people who are
Jewish
excluded people who are Latino that is
actually against the fair housing
standards Act of 1968 so to me that's an
example of crossing a very big line so
instead of just saying okay if I'm
searching for you know tennis rackets
and showing me an ad about tennis
rackets going that extra mile and saying
because I know everything you've been
writing and I know that tennis is really
important to you and I know that you
spend on average five hundred and
sixty-seven dollars per year on tennis
related paraphernalia I'm going to sell
an advertiser a super targeted ad to
just reach you I mean to me that's
that's that's creepy that just gets to
the it's it's not so much about privacy
it's about this ability to sort of
algorithmically target on
characteristics we may not want the
world to know that and even more
insidious use of data to me is if you
look at the recent agreement by 23 and
meet with one of the big pharma
companies to hand over their data and it
was for billions of dollars now the
thing I really think is kind of
objectionable about that is you've
already paid to have that data analyzed
you've not necessarily given 23andme
permission to further monetize that data
just because they have it to other
people so you know to me there's a huge
amount of institutional lag here you
know our rules about property rights and
your rights to your own data are so far
behind practice that I think we're in
for a big reckoning
[Music]